thank you alejandro yes i'm here with uh
shaq riyar momentaril a man with a plan
going into today's round
uh shaq when did you decide on making
this quick draw
okay i see here from
the java game how do we draw like this
because
it looks very interesting very nice
throw
but isaac is normal and okay tournament
station for misdraw is very good results
uh
i understand the answer also because he
played with black and
he played yesterday not easy game
long game and the draw is good results
for me his
tournament station his draw you've been
giving us a lot of excitement of course
uh tomorrow what's the plan tomorrow is
plans not to lose of course we will try
but
i don't know about this
i know for myself when i want to win too
much
i do some risky sometimes it's going
something wrong
and for this reason today draw and
tomorrow we will see
i think it's tomorrow we will play and
maxim
okay i don't know what about tomorrow
and but today's withdrawal is good
results for me
tomorrow definitely looking forward to
see uh what
your game is going to be bring to the
table guys back to you in the studio
thank you